.
>> KATIE BO LILLIS, THANK YOU.
>>> U.S. INTEL OFFICIALS SAY
RUSSIAN MILITARY LEADERS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT HOW AND WHEN THEY
WOULD USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON IN
UKRAINE.
NOW ON ITS FACE THAT'S ALARMING
BUT SOME U.S. OFFICIALS ARE
DIVIDED ON JUST HOW SERIOUS THE
THREAT REALLY IS.
KEEP IN MIND THE PENTAGON
ESTIMATES THAT RUSSIA HAS AN
ACTIVE STOCKPILE OF UP TO 2,000
NONSTRATEGIC NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
CNN WHITE HOUSE REPORTER NATASHA
BERTRAND JOINS US.
WHY THE DIFFERING OPINION?
>> Reporter: THE DIFFERENTIATION
REALLY HINGES ON THE SOURCING IN
THIS INTELLIGENCE PRODUCT.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO BELIEVE IT IS
THINLY SOURCED.
THAT IT IS MOSTLY ANALYSIS
WHEREAS OTHERS ARE VIEWING IT
WITH MORE CONCERN.
BROADLY THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THERE IS THIS
INTELLIGENCE THAT SUGGESTS THAT
THE RUSSIAN GENERALS HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING ABOUT HOW AND WHEN THEY
MIGHT USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON IN
UKRAINE, BASICALLY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY DEPLOY THAT
NUCLEAR WEAPON BUT THE
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION HERE COMES
INTO PLAY WHEN YOU CONSIDER HOW
THE PEOPLE, THE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE ACTUALLY
INTERPRETING THIS INTELLIGENCE.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, THIS IS NOT
A MONOLITH.
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS A PERFECT
SCIENCE.
INTELLIGENCE REQUIRES A LOT OF
INTERPRETATION AND SOME
OFFICIALS SAID THEY BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THIS CONVERSATION
REFLECTED IN THIS NEW
INTELLIGENCE ANALYSIS COULD BE
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT, THAT IT
HAS BEEN MISINTERPRETED BUT,
LOOK, OTHERS SAY THIS SHOULD BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY BECAUSE OF ALL
OF THE RHETORIC THAT WE HAVE
HEARD COMING FROM THE RUSSIANS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS AND,
OF COURSE, THE BATTLEFIELD
LOSSES THAT THEY ARE SUSTAINING
IN UKRAINE.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE HEARD THAT
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAS SAID IN SPEECHES THAT THE
RUSSIANS WOULD BE WILLING TO USE
SUCH A WEAPON IF NECESSARY AND
SO THEY'RE WATCHING THIS, THE
U.S. IS WATCHING THIS WITH A LOT
OF CONCERN AS TO HOW THIS PLAYS
OUT BUT SO FAR NO REAL CONSENSUS
ON HOW REAL THIS IS AND
IMMINENT, ANA.
>> WHAT IS THAT THRESHOLD IS THE
BIG QUESTION FOR THE KREMLIN TO
TAKE THAT HORRIFIC AND UN, YOU
KNOW, BELIEVABLE REALLY STEP.
THANK YOU, NATASHA BERTRAND.
>>> WE ARE GETTING NEW VIDEO I
WANT TO SHOW YOU ALLEGEDLY
SHOWING PUTIN'S MILITARY
HELICOPTERS BEING SABOTAGED DEEP
INSIDE RUSSIA MORE THAN 600
MILES FROM UKRAINE.
YOU CAN SEE AN UNIDENTIFIED MAN
APPEARING TO PREPARE AND
PLANTING EXPLOSIVES ON TO AN
AIRCRAFT.
AT TYPES HE HOLDS WHAT COULD BE
A TIMER TO HIS EAR.
CNN TRACED THIS VIDEO TO AN
AIRFIELD IN RUSSIA.
EXPLOSIONS REPORTED THAT NIGHT
AND A SATELLITE IMAGE LATER
SHOWS SEVERAL DAMAGED
HELICOPTERS THERE.
UKRAINE IS NOT DIRECTLY SAYING
WHETHER IT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS ATTACK, BUT SAYS TH